gerade die aktuelle meldung herein
gekommen dass es dem mädchen offenbar
gut geht und bei dieser sekte sei welche
informationen hast du wie ist die
polizei bisher vorgegangen
ja das ist im prinzip auch das was jetzt
wirklich vor wenigen minuten hier als
meldung eingegangen ist dass sich die
sekte gemeldet haben soll und gemeldet
haben soll dass ihr dass die tochter die
shalom jetzt wohl bei ihren pflege bei
ihren leiblichen eltern eben um dieser
sektor wieder sein soll das ist ja auch
das was ihr pflegevater der hier hinter
uns wohnt auch vermutet hat uns gestern
schon mitgeteilt hat dass er davon
ausgeht dass die pflege dass die
leiblichen eltern eben nicht hier nach
willigen gekommen sind in bayern um ihre
tochter dann abzuholen und mehr oder
weniger zu entführen die polizei hat
hier gestern mit einem großaufgebot auch
mit feuerwehr und rettungskräften das
den ganzen landkreis hier abgesucht
durch die felder durch die wälder auch
mit einem hubschrauber mit
wärmebildkameras vielen spürhunden haben
sie versucht hier doch das schlimmste
auszuschließen dass immerhin die kleine
shalom hier nicht irgendwo in den
feldern oder in dem wald verloren
gegangen ist und wie du gerade schon
angesprochen hast scheint es sich jetzt
zu bestätigen dass sie tatsächlich an
ihren eigenen leiblichen eltern entführt
worden ist die spürhunde haben gestern
hier die ihre spur bis zu einer straße
nachverfolgen können wo sie eben gestern
joggen gegangen ist ja und dort verlor
sich dann ihre spur und man vermutet
eben dass sie dort dann in das auto
eingestiegen ist zumindest die gute
nachricht dass das mädchen lebte was
kannst du uns zu den
familienverhältnissen sagen wie war das
verhältnis zwischen shalom an ihren
leiblichen eltern und auch den
pflegeeltern untereinander
ja wie kann eben schon angesprochen hat
ist paloma eines der kinder das vor acht
jahren aus dieser deckt den zwölf stämme
neben herausgenommen wurde vom jugendamt
und dann hier in dillingen untergekommen
ist das ist nur wenige kilometer
entfernt von nördlingen wo das damals
passiert ist wie es dann in eine
pflegefamilie hier untergekommen wo sie
eigentlich in sehr behüteten
verhältnissen an die letzten acht jahre
aufgewachsen ist auch mit drei anderen
pflege gehen dann in dieser familie
erleben wir haben gestern auch die
chance gehabt mit dem pflegevater zu
reden
allerdings muss man sagen hat mir auch
über die ganzen jahre weiterhin kontakt
zu ihren leiblichen eltern die auch alle
sechs wochen ungefähr wie hier besuchen
konnten ja und uns wurde vom pflegevater
geschildert dass er eigentlich auch ein
liebevolles verhältnis zu beiden
familien hat also sowohl ihrer
pflegefamilie als auch zu den leiblichen
eltern die sie jetzt eben mutmaßlich
wieder zurückholen wollen
das wird jetzt passieren wie wird die
polizei vorgehen oder auch die
pflegeeltern werden sie das kind
zurückholen
naja das ist jetzt die grosse frage weil
eben nicht klar ist wo sich denn die
kleine stromer im moment aufhält alles
was wir wissen ist dass sie eben am
samstag zwischen 14 und 15 uhr
losgegangen ist zum joggen und dann
nicht mehr aufgetaucht ist wo sie sich
aktuell auf fällt wissen wir nicht die
eltern also die leiblichen eltern sind
wohl in den letzten zwei tagen auch
nicht mehr zu hause in tschechien
gewesen sondern möglicherweise hier
schon vor ort in dillingen und haben ihr
möglicherweise hier eben auch
aufgelauert und wo die beiden sich jetzt
oder die 30 jetzt befinden vielleicht
auch zusammen mit ihren geschwistern
wird nämlich auch zwei geschwister das
wissen wir nicht sollte sie dort jetzt
tatsächlich aufgefunden werden dann von
der polizei die ja auch schon bei ihren
leiblichen eltern vor ort war aber dort
niemand binden konnte dann besteht
natürlich die möglichkeit dass sie
wieder zurückgeführt wird zu ihrer
pflegefamilie
aber das steht jetzt gerade noch in den
sternen die meldungen dass jetzt bei
ihren leiblichen eltern sein soll ist
lässt zumindest mal aufatmen das ist ihr
körperlich gut geht aber dass damit ist
natürlich die messe noch nicht gelesen
jetzt muss es darum gehen sie auch auf
zu finden und dann wird sich weiteres
ergeben
[Musik]